but movie stars also please fans and
I've heard you tell a story about Rob
Reiner and I think we'll you going to
Disneyland or Disney World isn't this
was this was this was so surreal neither
one of us could breathe it long ago Rob
Reiner and we took our kids to
Disneyland the whole family the kids
were little and as we're coming back
we're stuck in traffic on the 405 and
we're going very slowly but I'm driving
and Rob is in the shotgun seat and
there's one of the buses that takes
people to and from the airport
oh yeah and because they will get stuck
in traffic a lot they show movies on
screens in in this in the bus and so
we're stuck we're going back and forth
and we look on this bus that's right
next to us in the other lane and said
Sleepless in Seattle is playing in that
bus Rob and I were both in Sleepless in
Seattle and we're looking at this thing
and there's a guy's kind of looking at
it like this and we say oh my god
they're almost up to our scene where we
have a talk at a coffee shop but I said
oh my god but bears are seen you see the
song so i tooted the horn and the guy
who is like look at this
I've always wondered what did that guy
tell the wife what do you got flying
honey the flight was nothing but this
bus drop
[Applause]
you